step on a chair I'm brian Stelter
affirmative CNN's reliable sources when
they asked me to moderate this
discussion I thought Gary P needs no
moderating go ahead and then play along
and as I asked you I think might be a
tough question you did not want to hear
this question ahead of time so will be a
surprise
tell them how improv I really am you you
swore you did not want to know I was
trying to prep you here's what I want
you to do I wanted to tell us something
about your business and your brand you
never told anyone before oh [ __ ] that is
hard the single I ought a lot about
making a lot of money selling baseball
cards but the single biggest profit play
I ever made as a youngster before I got
in my dad's business was the dollar
stores had just come out in the mid 90s
and they weren't selling product that
were made for dollar stores they were
still dollar stores where they would buy
old inventory in warehouses bring it in
and so they were complete hodgepodge
random stuff yeah out of nowhere I used
to go to them look at them and see if I
could find some baseball card or
football card stuff to sell it shows out
of nowhere in the height of Shaquille
O'Neal's rookie year when there was Shaq
toys for some unknown reason a dollar
store in Phillipston Mall got a crap
load of Shaq figures at a dollar apiece
now this is 1993 I buy them and then
walk oh I don't know probably from here
- to the curtain over there which was
where the dollar store was versus where
Kmart was in this small store and I in
between my walk I switched the 10
figures out of the dollar store bag and
into a Kmart bag that I went and got
from Kmart and went back to the dollar
store and returned them at Kmart with no
receipt because he didn't need one back
then and Kmart was selling them for
$9.99 apiece
and for a three-week period I made
almost ten thousand dollars buying Shack
figures for a dollar and then selling
them back to Kmart for $9.99 cash now
tell us how we can do that in this
current economic environment where do
you see that that arbitrage I think
garage saleing there's a big ROI play
yes because the garage sale eBay
conversion has some of the biggest
margins in the world I truly believe
that it that every person can make a
thousand dollars a week by waking up at
five o'clock in the morning garage
saleing on a Saturday for four hours and
then posting the stuff they find on eBay
oh that's a serious thing I think it
actually is because a lot of people like
how do I make money like it's right
there like literally become educated on
VHS and DVD and CD like arbitrage on
eBay because everybody's selling them at
garage sales for like three bucks for a
box of them and you will make a thousand
dollars every weekend
it's very lots a thousand dollars so
really very practical session already I
love it I like practicality people know
you want to order people online that
know them too I'm actually divvy up your
day what is a day in your life they're
all different they you know today is
right here's my day we've got this grant
worked out this morning we've got this I
have to rush back now in a meeting with
the new CMO of North America for Pepsi
for an hour then I've got a couple of
in-house meetings then I've got a call
I'm raising a new fund so I've got some
LP calls trying to get some money then I
have to run to Mondelez the former Kraft
in New Jersey a client we have a
four-hour session for the future of econ
with them that we're consulting on then
I have to drive to New York Airport I
have a couple calls in there I fly to
Vegas I land in Vegas I have a quick
meeting on somebody I'm interviewing
then I have to wake up in the morning
and I have two speeches in Vegas time
it's always different I speak but I run
vaynermedia I run vayner/rse and then
you know Dee rocks over there we create
content I do the show
on the flight to Vegas I have to edit my
new book and get the final touches so
you know 80% vaynermedia and the and the
fund and then a little bit of Wine
Library and my personal brand stuff like
every minute is so precious I have a
full-time assistant everything it's very
intense
like he locks on the glass if I'm a few
minutes behind like every minute is so
precious and then on top of that she's
actually working 18 hours a day like my
I left the office last night at eleven
forty nine you know and so like that's
real like well I I think I think the
thing that I spew a lot and I know a lot
of people by the faces here know my
spiel like I just I'm trying to connect
the dots in my own mind how to get
people to really understand especially
if your startup or trying to start your
own thing like the amount of people that
have startups in this city and are at
New York City the grind hustle city and
are really willing to stop working on
their company at seven o'clock and then
go out for drinks or whatever it blows
my mind that people really understand
the level of time and full all-in
commitment it takes to have the number
one best thing that can happen in your
life professionally which is living on
your own terms
owning your own business that
financially pays for your life and your
happiness and you're not willing to put
it all on the table especially when
you're still not in a chapter in your
life where you don't have as many
responsibilities it speaks to what I
know is going on right now which is this
is the single greatest generation of
fake entrepreneurs of all time
it's true it's it's and the reason I
want to say it is I want it to be on all
these cameras because in six years when
we all look back at this generation and
post-game it will be like that was the
greatest generation of fake
entrepreneurs of all time mainly because
it's so easy everybody coming out of
school now you know how old are you so
your youngster yeah I'm 39 my generation
people didn't think they were gonna
start their businesses coming out of
school you wouldn't got a job every
single kid that I run into now that's
under 22 years old defaults into an
entitlement that they're gonna run and
own their own company and on their idea
people are gonna give them millions of
dollars to start it it's a broken game
and it's gonna be straight carnage no no
Millennials are [ __ ] rad I'm all in
on Millennials by the way this is
happening with 40 and 50 year olds too
there's a lack of self-awareness and
it's been you know what there's
something else it's not a Millennials
fault if you're 22 right 9/11 happened
before you can even remember oma right
the last economic bus you know 2008/9
we're starting it far away if you're 14
when that happens you're not really
thinking about that right and so it's
just the times just have been too good
in the tech sector we're not in Middle
America like the the the game is great
like the economy is great like people
are what happened is people make money
every dentist and lawyer and rich guy or
gal is looking for their Mark Zuckerberg
they're playing the lotto they're being
affected by what happened they want to
write a $50,000 check or $25,000 check
they have their friends there at work
they're 52 they have money their friends
like my son has a big idea and they're
like oh I want to invest in that and so
that 22 year olds getting a hundred K
for me lawyer Johnny McGee because I
think I'm gonna turn that hundred
thousand into 48 million because I read
an article about uber or Facebook guys
there's like seven companies that have
put like made it insane
and then there's 70,000 a week that die
and so I think we're in a very um and
I'm trying to navigate this because
after everything I just said you're
investing all day because there will be
and here's why because at the same token
there will be hundreds of businesses
built this year that will be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars because
this is the Second Industrial Revolution
there is a land grab every business is
going to be disrupted so you've got a
really difficult game I wish it was as
simple as it was the first web 1.0
bubble because I would just sit on money
and wait for the carnage and buy things
on a nickel on the dollar the problem is
that's not what's happening there's real
[ __ ] being built real opportunity so
you're you're navigating through a very
difficult minefield
absolutely for me I'm good because
because I'm a wartime general meaning I
built both of my businesses during down
times I built wine library after 9/11
where my entire business was Wall Street
and wine so like i neva gated through
that I started vaynermedia right after
the financial crisis and I was selling
social media
nobody wanted to buy it I'm an immigrant
I like zero I like being a wartime
general so I'm actually weirdly just
waiting for [ __ ] to hit the fan like I
want to wake up and hear that Wall
Street did it again we're all [ __ ] you
know I'm waiting for that and by the way
like you all know that's what's
happening right like those [ __ ]
characters yes I think that agencies are
broken in their strategies because most
of their clients sell in an American
market to America right and and all
their offices are in LA San Francisco in
New York and those are three complete
outliers as cities to America they just
are Pepsi right Unilever you know Kraft
Mondelez Toyota I mean every business in
America sells to all of America unless
you're a niche product that sells to the
coasts because you're the milk of a
monkey's ass right you know and I
and it's $47 for a couple you know so
you know what I mean Brian like every
big business any fortune 500 company
relies on their sales in every state and
and wait I mean all of us that are here
we are in a very different mindset than
when you know the benefit of doing a
book tour and what people consider
second third fourth year I don't need I
don't even do Chicago in Dallas I'm
trying to do a mapping and now my head
it's like Des Moines and Columbus Ohio
like this is real places where Dollar
General and Walmart and Costco rule the
day and I want to make sure that my
agency understands where this stuff is
being sold and the psychology of
somebody who literally is saving every
dollar and every penny doesn't buy $8
juice and is living that lifestyle I
mean I I have kids that work for me that
I know what they get paid I know them
personally so I know what support were
not support they're getting from their
parents I know they're living on a
budget they have four and a half
roommates and they're buying $11 cold
coffee every day and I'm like [ __ ] these
kids are on a different [ __ ] right and
so that's cool and not only are they
buying $11 cold coffee they're going to
Coachella the Kentucky Derby and 17
weeks and [ __ ] amps rim because we
don't have a vacation policy right so so
they're playing a different game their
minds in a different place they value
different things and then I think about
a 36 year old bomb in Arkansas who every
[ __ ] penny matters and she stressed
because she's a mother and cares about
her children and the pressure of how we
have to feed our children and equality
food and the expense of that versus what
she can afford and how do we help her
how do we motivate her how do we educate
her how do we lead her towards whatever
goals we have in business those are two
different psyches and it's hard for me
to assume my 24 year old that grew up on
the Upper East Side in Manhattan with
the private schools in networks at
vaynermedia can have the empathy to
deploy himself to the 36 year old mom in
Arkansas yeah you know though it's
actually by this interesting way you put
it like to me it's all kind of been the
same which is reverse-engineer how to
bring the most disproportionate value to
whoever's paying attention to you around
the subject matter so it's the same
thesis the Wine Library it was
broken in America nobody cares about
wine because everybody talks down to
people about wine I know a crapload
about wine I'm a Jersey boy I'm not
gonna talk down to anybody let me start
this and talk to people about wine and
maybe we'll convert some of these young
dudes that may now think wines cooler
than just drinking a beer or liquor and
that's basically what happened let me
use youtube when it just was invented
and let me do that that worked social
crush it when I wrote it was hey there's
a real way now with YouTube and Twitter
and Facebook to build a business on your
terms I wrote that and now with
vaynermedia it's like hey big businesses
midsize businesses there's a real way to
not waste money on all the marketing
behavior so I'm and even what we talked
about there you know back to our
conversation before we came here you
said hey there's London there's this I
said let's not talk about that let's
figure out how to bring them value if
you default into bringing value to your
audience regardless of what your subject
matter is you will always win because
you've won the leverage game of
providing value first what is your
strategy for creating content you've got
a sort of virtuous cycle of this right
yes always producing we came up with a
pretty good concept obviously a lot of
you watched the show and know Dirac and
India and they're part of a team that is
basically a production team for my brand
but we needed something to be a starting
point and the reason I started the
askgaryvee show was i knew that it was
the best way for me to start producing
content that wasn't naturally bubbling
up in my own head when you get to ask
the questions you're asking me different
things that aren't on my mind I put out
the show that's a piece of content but
then those five answers are starting
points to other content in India or or
Steve will come to me and say hey that
second answer you haven't talked a lot
about parenting they'll ask me five or
six other questions that becomes the
framework of a medium post or a LinkedIn
post or a Facebook long-form post so by
doing the show every day
it's my seed to create the level of
content on you and listen it's been
interesting all my successful friends
all my people that are paying attention
I've especially the last three four
months so many people coming up to me
and like man the level and the amount of
content that you're putting out just
seems insane it's because there was a
really smart strategy 15 months ago
let's
a show that forces me to consistent put
out content let's then use those seeds
to grow out more pieces of content and
we've literally are you know D rocks
filming now yes we may show this in its
entirety or I might have just said
something and that will turn into three
different articles we're just always on
collecting and using those as the
gateway drugs to longer form content so
daily is a model you have to force
yourself to in here to keep creating I
think it's very hard to create
compelling content on a daily basis and
I think that everybody here knows that
it's not easy and so I think Q&A is a
very intriguing way to get there because
you're using the incredible skills of
others Facebook yes facebook facebook is
the Beast Facebook is the foundation
Facebook is grossly underestimated by
the the most intense tech people because
they want to be on to the next thing but
the scale of Facebook the ability to
spend a little bit of money and target
if I want to target I'm getting a lot of
TV offers right now because I'm running
the askgaryvee show
against paid against production
companies on TV now I don't want to do a
TV show I'm just doing it mainly for my
ego but it was really more of a test to
see if I started running this show
against employees of production
companies when I start getting more cold
emails about doing a TV show and it's
been insane it's a heck of a way to get
a resume
yeah I mean all these people like how
did you raise money from a VC how do you
get a TV show how do you get a book deal
easy have them come to you
you say well easy
aka if you don't have talent you're not
gonna get any of those [ __ ] things so
I love like you know this is back to
like everybody feeling they're entitled
to being an entrepreneur like like if
you're not smart and charismatic and
compelling to listen to or watch and you
want to be a personal brand
you lost it's a prerequisite I want to
be the quarterback of the New York Jets
I lost like like you know I love when
people like Gary I'm gonna do what
you're gonna do I'm like you didn't even
look me in the eye when you just said
that you're weird as [ __ ] you're not
doing [ __ ] you know like so so I think I
think self-awareness is something that
needs to start being talked about a
little bit as well I'm I'm an investor
and snapchat heavily I'm a huge believer
in snapchat I'm spending just to make it
black here's an exclusive I am
negotiating on a daily basis to try to
get a snapchat show on discovery because
I want every sixteen-year-old
entrepreneur to think I'm the guy it's
the gateway drug like CNN you know had
its you know 1990 Iran you know Iraq war
there was its watershed moment 24-hour
news the internets had its saying like
snapchat i like when people write
articles snapchat is this generations
MTV they're so wrong snapchat to a 14 to
22 year old is the entire cable industry
I mean every 15 year old girl America if
you're just curious about what they do
they go home whenever they're done if
they have after-school activities
whatever but when I'm gonna get home
whether it's four or seven or whatever
the second they get home they go to the
room close the door they jump on their
bed they grab their phone and they stay
on snapchat until they go to sleep
for hours and so people are grossly
under estimating 125 million daily
active users that are spending hours on
the platform looks like and so there's a
gross underestimate of what's really
happening there and yes I'm desperately
trying to impose my will into that
platform because I will have a
disproportionate lead as the
entrepreneur to that generation when
they start hitting the market five six
years from now to this point to some
older people it's as if snapchats not
right upon us here's I'm oh that's a I'm
really glad you asked this question
everything that you're about to watch
for the next thirty years with humans is
pendulum swings social media everybody
tell everybody about everything right
momentum went this way happened for a
couple years all the momentum all the
conversation everybody bet on it every
app tried to do it and then all of a
sudden snapchat came along and said now
wait a minute
in real life when we talk those things
disappear privacy has value let's push
the other way and so they found their
whitespace
I actually am already starting to figure
out what's the swing back to open in a
post snapchat world five years from now
inspirational amazing
thank you well I wasn't doing health and
wellness as of you know June of last
year
and finally I've been thinking about it
for a while and I finally figured out
what was happening which is I believe
with health and wellness and probably
most probably everything
you're either accountable to yourself or
you're not unless you and so in every
other part of my life I'm accountable I
feel accountable especially with my
businesses like the the rigor the the
sense of responsibility I have for the
other 550 employees is greater than my
own well-being and when I said that
notice even how I said the sentence I
just said I'm accountable myself but I
explained it as I was accountable to
other people and I what I just did with
you by accident is how I figured this
out I was like what's the matter
me I'm gonna die like I'm gonna lose
like the last like or I'm not gonna be
able to do as many cool things like this
is not gonna work this this is black and
white I'm gonna treat my body like a
business I bought it it I'm gonna lose
I've lost and so then I said why is that
I'm so good at everything these other
things and I realized holy crap the
things I'm best at
or when I'm accountable to somebody but
not myself so I realized I'm gonna
introduce a person I'm gonna hire a
full-time health person and I'm more
accountable to Mike than I am to myself
the reason I work out every single day
is I don't want to let Mike down I have
to be down at 5:45 because Mike's gonna
be upset and so I hacked myself and so
where do I find health I just I found it
like I just do it every day there's an
hour every day scheduled like period end
of story
I work out every day of my life and I
changed my eating behavior because of it
because [ __ ] if I'm gonna do the work
you know and and that's how I hacked it
I reverse engineered what I was doing I
think I think everybody here is either
accountable to themselves or accountable
to others and you need to self audit
yourself and figure out if you're not
doing well in business maybe you need to
hire a couple of employees because maybe
you'll feel a sense of responsibility to
them maybe that's the motivation you're
looking for yes Mike isn't going on a
fly and usually comes she travels with
me the whole nine but this is a quick
in-and-out but I will have to FaceTime
with him while I do cardio because I
truly if I don't won't do it as well my
parents and that's it and I know it's
like I get mad at this question because
I feel like it's either cliche or maybe
I always ask myself am I too egotistical
to give it to somebody else it's just
the truth like I don't look at you on
musk or sucks or Cuban or the president
or I don't do that it's just not real
it's just not true I look at my parents
I know their treats I know they came
this country with nothing you know I
know I know that my dad worked every
minute I didn't know him till I was 14 I
know that my mom is the foundation of my
self-esteem which is the driving fuel of
my success um there's just there's not
even a close second to the entity of my
parents and I I don't know these other
people I know their public persona in
the same way that a lot of you don't
know me as an effect the thing I
probably am happiest about in the world
is the people that come into vaynermedia
that have some sense of me I think like
me a lot more two or three years later
when they get to look under the hood but
I'm too scared maybe to even give that
away to somebody else without knowing
that I don't have the time to look under
the hood yes you're not skilled so this
brain powers little short
you don't work very hard you know show
up they don't like it when I tell them
that and so the interesting part is that
when I'm working with them and some of
them have a chance what's your
perspective on dealing with the
younglings as a day one guy how do you
get to do stuff without telling them
they're stupid and lazy I I actually I
actually think of it in Reverse I mean
most of my 22 and 23 year olds would
look in your face and think that you're
finished and let they [ __ ] you
yeah don't care make money fall out of
the sky they tell me it's irrelevant but
the question it's not that it's not
about cool or what have you you what you
define as money might be different than
the way they define is money like okay
cool how much one you gonna make for
your twenty three-year-old give me mama
no no not for them Rick doesn't get
forty million dollars how much does Rick
the twenty three-year-old get and
getting the truth because the number
isn't high owner other company I mean I
don't know about have been probably into
three billion bucks
compensation this year explain let's go
further I want to know how a twenty
three-year-old
okay I have an old school web strategy
yeah I know what works yes and the email
do the best put in the time every day
don't want to do that it's a
communication problem for me so let me
ask you a question
yeah don't you just do it for yourself
yeah that's the real question
right like cool if you know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about do for
yourself I do I work harder and I'm
smarter than all my 22 year olds
I'm better at social media than
everybody at vaynermedia I'm looking at
them right now just to remind them like
so so so honestly I think you're rolling
with like trying to razz them razz
yourself like why are you trying to
funnel through a twenty three-year-old
thank you